c'est tout bon soir merci d'être avec
nous merci pour la preuve d'unité vous
allez bien je vais bien alors on voit
depuis le début de cette campagne que
vous voulez vraiment recentrer le parti
conservateur vous avez notamment
présenté un plan sur l'environnement
mais s'il ya un mais mais là la plupart
de vos militants n'ont pas voulu
reconnaître l'existence même des
changements climatiques en mars dernier
ne commence que les canadiens peuvent
vous faire confiance que vous êtes
sérieuse sur cet enjeu de
l'environnement maintenant je suis un
nouveau chef vec une nouvelle approche
et les changements climatiques est un
enjeu important pour moi comme un
politicien mais comme une perte de
famille aussi et ici pourquoi en avril
j'ai lancé notre politique sur les
changements climatiques
on va atteindre nos objectifs de paray
paris tout en protégeant les emplois et
on a un plan pour une relance économique
aussi muni des changements climatiques
l'environnement sont importants pour
notre parti et je vais travailler très
fort sur les changements climatiques
qu'est ce que ça veut dire que tous vos
candidats croient en l'existence des
changements climatiques même des
candidats comme cheryl gallant qui a
propagé les théories du complot sur le
climat
tous nos candidats sont en accord avec
notre plan au début de la campagne j'ai
lancé notre que plan pour le
rétablissement du canada avec notre
politique sur le changement climatique
on doit atteindre nos objectifs
c'est important pour notre parti est
d'avoir une relance économique après la
pandémie aussi c'est possible d'avoir
les deux et je vais travailler très fort
sur tous nos politiques c'est le temps
pour une plan d'action sur les emplois
et sur l'environnement aussi est ce que
ça veut dire que tous les candidats qui
seraient pas prêts à accepter ce plan
seraient exclues de votre caucus
éventuellement donc tout le monde sont
en accord avec notre plan je suis fier
de notre toit on a lancé au début de la
campagne on va avoir cinq piliers les
emplois une loi anticorruption la santé
mentale
un plan d'être plus près pour les
pandémies et un plan d'équilibrer le
budget et les changements climatiques
est une priorité pour moi comme j'ai dit
et on doit agir sur les priorités alors
parlons de ce plan vous dites que vous
allez respecter les cibles de l'accord
de paris réduction de 30% des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre mais les
nouvelles cibles international du canada
ces 40 à 45 % si vous devenez premier
ministre est ce que vous allez respecter
ces nouvelles cibles canadiennes on a un
plan de d'atteindre nos objectifs de
paris et on doit faire ça mais surtout
d'eau a manqué ses objectifs
chaque année par romanès com com est
menacée inacceptable et canadiens de
québécois méritent un plan réel on doit
réduire les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre tout en respectant une relance
économique après les premiers et on va
travailler avec les provinces sur ça on
a beaucoup de détails dans notre
plateforme sur
l'environnement le changement climatique
comme j'ai dit je vais travailler avec
les provinces pour nos objectifs mais
est-ce que c'est 30 ou est-ce que c'est
40 30 maintenant parce que on doit
atteindre nos objectifs
et c'est la même chose pour nos alliés
aussi il y a beaucoup d'ambition mais
pas un plan concret j'ai lancé un plan
concret j'ai travaillé en étroite
collaboration avec les consultants verts
d'avoir un plan real et c'est important
pour notre parti de rétablir la
confiance des canadiens et des québécois
dans notre approche comme j'ai dit je
suis nouveau chef avec une nouvelle
approche et j'ai travaillé dans le
secteur privé sur les enjeux
environnementaux aussi et c'est
important pour moi personnellement oui
mais sauf que est-ce que c'est suffisant
parce que les états unis par exemple 50
52 % de réduction la grande
le royaume uni soixante dix huit pour
cent le canada est vraiment en retard là
dessus on en reste il faut pas augmenter
et faire preuve d'un peu d'ambition à ce
niveau là on va voir les résultats avec
nos alliés et on a un autre utilité
d'améliorer nos relations avec les états
unis est de travailler en partenariat
comme monsieur moore unis a fait a déjà
donc on doit travailler avec un plan
concret canadien et c'est important
d'avoir une relance économique parce que
avec une économie force est possible de
lutter contre les changements
climatiques les inégalités la
réconciliation on doit voir une relance
à travers le pays parce que même pour la
taxe sur le carbone pour vous cette
fois-ci vous reconnaissez maintenant que
c'est un bon outil pour essayer de
réduire les émissions mais vous la
plafonner à
une taxe de 50 $ pour le parti pour les
particuliers est-ce que c'est pas
seulement symbolique parce qu'au fond ça
va coûter moins cher de polluer avec un
gouvernement comprenant un prix sur le
carbone et c'était un changement pour
notre parti bien sûr mais c'est très
important pour notre pain d'atteindre
nos objectifs et tous les canadiens et
canadiens avec notre pain va comprendre
leur un prêt carbone et on doit
travailler ensemble les familles les
fermes les entreprises et les grandes
météo aussi et on a un plan avec
beaucoup d idées sur les changements
climatiques et c'est important pour
notre parti d'atteindre nos objectifs
combien de nouveaux pipelines vous
voulez construire au canada monsieur
autour pour sortir pour exporter le
pétrole de l'alberta les emplois honneur
bretons sont importants il y à une crise
de confiance dans notre pays maintenant
après six ans admis surtout d'eau et on
doit rétablir la confiance dans l'ouest
30 ce matin est un oléoduc très
important de l'avant avec vous oui
oui aussi c'était un exemple d'une
partenariat avec les premières nations
là-bas mais monsieur trudeau a annulé
sans concertation avec les pros ma
nation s'est développée qui voudraient y
construire le nord est est une est un
gars diot de colo deux importants mais
les deux sont suffisants parce qu'on
voit quand même que dans votre plan que
vous voulez encore développer cette
industrie pétrolière yapo question fait
comme si de rien n'était on continue
malgré les feux de forêt malgré tout ce
qu'on l'a vu cet été les canicules il
faut aller de l'avant vous dites avec
l'industrie patron doit agir sur le
changement climatique tout en respectant
l'économie et les les familles canadien
dans l'ouest au québec mais une relance
économique et on doit réduire nos
émissions et je vais travailler avec les
grandes émetteurs en alberta dans les
autres industries pour un plan d'être
carbone neutre par
2050 c'est très important pour notre
pays est ce que vous pourriez imposer un
pipeline comme celui d' énergie s par
exemple au québec parce que quand vous
étiez dans la course à la direction du
parti vous vouliez une nouvelle un
projet de loi qui autoriserait le
fédéral a imposé le pipeline partout au
canada est ce que c'est ce qu'on
pourrait voir un autre people et les les
oléoducs de france et noir dulgheru et
son importance et mes priorités et on
doit rétablir la confiance des canadiens
dans le west dans notre pays après six
ans de monsieur to do il y a plus de
divisions dans notre pays et on doit
travailler ensemble pour une relance
économique et c'est pourquoi je vais
respecter les gentils compétences des
provinces et leur bien-être comme une
économie et c je suis fier de nos
secteurs à deir ezzor ce naturel dans
l'oise le bois d'herve ici au québec a
les mines aussi nous sommes plus vert
que tous les autres pays dans le monde
vraiment un endroit on doit travailler
en étroite collaboration avec
les les entrepreneurs les entreprises
pour réduire les émissions et avoir
entre leurs économies donc pour ce soit
clair est-ce que vous nous garantissez
qui en aura pas ou vous n'excluez pas
gagné on va cibler sur à 30 et northern
gateway seulement donc il n'aura pas au
québec oui c'est on doit travailler en
partenariat avec les provinces j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour primer menace
le goût on a eu dire des réunions on a
parlé sur la langue la culture
québécoise on doit travailler ensemble
sur une relance économique et les
priorités en commun
il y avait un projet de jeu reprend la
balle au bond y avait un projet
monsieur autour d'un pipeline vers le
québec est ce que vous pourriez l'imposé
c'est ça la question non je vais
travailler avec les provinces incluant
monsieur legault on doit travailler
ensemble après six ans de divisions
comme j'ai déçu une province comme le
québec veut pas de pipeline n'y aurait
pas de public non parce que on a des
pipelines très jeune l'ouest vous avez
ça m'offre hâtez vous venez de citer
marbre on est bon on est au québec
monsieur maroni est-ce que vous citez
monsieur mulroney aussi dans l'ouest est
ce que c'est une inspiration politique
pour vous monsieur mulroney je suis un
nouveau chef et j'ai beaucoup de respect
pour tous les personnes en politique ah
et je pars avec les anciens dirigeants
de notre parti incluant monsieur moroni
particulièrement sur la situation avec
nos relations avec les etats-unis en
droit à améliorer la situation
c'était cette mauvaise situation avec
les tarifs sur le bois d'oeuvre les buy
american l'annulation de criston aline 5
il y à des risques avec nos relations
maintenant et on doit améliorer ça
monsieur autour vous avez dit je suis
pro choix point final arrêtez de me pose
la question je suis pro choix n'empêche
vous voulez laisser aux médecins
choix de refuser de faire pratiquer des
avortements
comment s'assurer que ça ne va pas
restreindre l'accès à l'avortement dans
certaines régions où il ya plus de
médecins comme comme vous le savez je
suis pochoir je veux toujours défendre
les droits des femmes pour deux choisis
pour elle-même et l'accès à l'avortement
est un service important à travers le
pays et ça serait mon approche comme
premier protéger les droits des
canadiens à travers le pays en
partenariat avec les provinces parce que
je vais augmenter les transferts en
santé avec une montant historique 60
milliards de dollars pour notre système
de santé public et universel mais sans
condition j'ai dit ça avec comme nice
legault c'est une question de respect
mais les services sont jouées mondiale
on va vous parler de sentiment d'une
seconde mais juste pour bien comprendre
parce que dans votre course au
leadership
javier dit on n'obligera pas un médecin
a référé à un autre médecin médecin qui
veut pas pratiquer un avortement on ne
l'oublient je repars référé un autre
médecin là vous avez changé d'idée donc
là vous êtes d'accord qu'on oblige les
médecins s'ils veulent pas pratiqué à
référé un médecin qui veut pratiquer en
avant j'ai gagné la course à la
chefferie comme une candidat pro choix
et je vais avoir une approche comme
quand même naissent pro-choix et l'accès
à l'avortement et est important c'est
une doigts et on doit respecter ça c'est
c'est possible d'avoir des
accommodations raisonnable pour les
médecins ou les infirmières avec les
services de l'aide médicale à mourir
mais l'accès et les les référents sont
importantes dans notre système public il
ya quarante députés de votre caucus qui
sont pro vie vous avez quand même il
faut le souligner gagné leadership avec
le vote
religieux surtout pour simplifier est ce
que vous pourriez nommer un député pro
vie comme ministre de la santé on a un
chef qui est pro choix et comme j'ai dit
je vais défendre les doigts pour les
femmes g j'ai fait ça comme un officier
dans les forces armées canadiennes
j'étais là pour les droits de notre pays
pour nos institutions et je vais avoir
un coach comme ça comme premier menace
je suis ici pour protéger nounou foyers
nos doigts et pour la prospérité pour
tous les canadiens tous les québécois
après la pandémie ici pourquoi j'ai
lancé mon plan pour le rétablissement du
canada mais je vais dur chaque jour je
suis pro choix et je vais défendre les
droits des femmes les droits de la
communauté lgbt q j'ai un bilan comme
alliés et c'est très important pour tous
les canadiens de comprends je suis ici
pour vos doigts merci monsieur toure
parlons pas des lilas quatrième vague
s'accélère risque de s'aggraver selon
l'agent de santé du canada les
non-vaccinés prolonge la pandémie
monsieur trudeau l'a dit que tout à
l'heure la quatrième vague c'est la
vague des non vaccinés vous êtes
personnellement vacciner mais vous êtes
d'abord ce soir dans cette campagne un
aspirant au poste de premier ministre
est ce que vous n'avez pas l'obligation
de présenter à la population une équipe
un gouvernement qui serait exemplaire et
qui épouserait la science
absolument c'est pourquoi chaque jour
j'encourage tous les canadiens tu les
québécois à se faire vacciner les
vaccins sont efficaces c'est sécuritaire
c'est très important dans notre lutte
contre la couvrir 19 c'est pourquoi ma
femme et moi on a enregistré nos
vaccination pour éduquer les canadiens
je vais toujours
respecté les décisions personnelles sur
la santé et c'est possible d'avoir un
approche avec les tests de dépistage
quotidienne les masques les mesures
sanitaires à pau les personnes non
vaccinées mais qu'elles sont et pour
votre équipe est-ce qu'il n'avait pas
l'obligation d'être exemplaire au nom de
la protection de la vie parce que vous
avez des pro vida les oppositions ce
paradoxe ici mais quand on veut être
premier ministre qu'on va avoir une
équipe maîtrise vous poser la question
pour un ministre la santé à l'avortement
est ce que vous pourriez nous et une
personnes non vaccinées au poste de
milieu de la santé qu'est-ce que ça
annonce comme politiques publiques tous
nos candidats et candidates doit
utiliser les vaccins ou une test de
dépistage quotidienne mais c'est
important et j'encourage les
vaccinations et c'est très important à
plein d'une pandémie d'avoir une
approche de travailler en collaboration
malheureusement nous sommes dans une
élection en pleine d'une pandémie à
cause d'une chute ou d'autres mais on
doit travailler ensemble et de respecter
les décisions personnelles sur la santé
des cas mais même quand on veut un tri
lui représenter l'ensemble des citoyens
la grande majorité des citoyens au
canada favorise la double vaccination
est est ce que votre leadership sont ici
n'est pas mis en cause de ne pas exiger
de vos candidats
cette double vaccination parce que vous
demandez la confiance des canadiens
absolument et c'est pourquoi nous
obligés d'être le seul appelé xijun
c'est très important pour tous les
canadiens de travailler ensemble contre
la courbe et 19 dans la quatrième vague
on doit utiliser les vaccins les vaccins
sont primordiales j'ai demandé un
approvisionnement suffisant des vaccins
il y a un an mais je vais respecter les
décisions personnelles des canadiens et
utiliser les autres utile parce que
c'est possible d'utiliser les tests les
dépistages rapides des masses des
mesures sanitaires pour protéger les
canadiens tous les médecins à travers le
pays de santé publique les plusieurs
gouvernements et particulièrement le
gouvernement du québec que vous dites
respectais beaucoup puis je vais vous
citer le ministre la santé du québec qui
dit que les non vaccinés prennent la
population vaccinée en otage qu'est ce
que vous pensez de la déclaration du
ministre la santé du québec monsieur
dubé où j'ai beaucoup de respect pour
lui et son travail dans la pandémie mais
on doit éduquer les canadiens et
québécois par forcer sur les questions
sur le propre santé et je suis un
rassembleur comme une chef à et je vais
toujours encore et j'ai éduqué et parler
en partenariat avec nos médecins nos nos
premiers ministres dans une lutte contre
la pandémie vous demander la confiance
de canadiens vous êtes aspirants premier
ministre dans votre parti on l'a dit
plus tôt leurs yeux des
climato-sceptiques l'an 54% du mmm ont
voté contre la reconnaissance des
changements climatiques on peut ajouter
des vaccinés au cpc qui permettra
peut-être sonné au néologisme on les a
vus dans les manifestations des
militants conservateurs ces derniers
jours exprimer leur rage face aux
mesures les pillages chirurgien qui
diffusent de la fausse information
disant qu'ils auraient confinement
climatique alors comment pouvons-nous
avoir confiance en une équipe aussi
variés dans l'est dans leur choix comme
j'ai dit je suis un nouveau chef et je
vais avoir une campagne positive
chaque jour et c'est pourquoi j'ai lancé
notre classement on va avoir un plan
pour notre paix après la pandémie et on
doit unir notre pays après six ans de
divisions avec monsieur trudeau et tous
mes candidats et tous mes candidats
devront avoir la même approche une
campagne positive basée sur notre plan
pour les fêter alors cheryl gallant vous
acceptez qu'elle reste député les deux
puissances au début des années 2000 vous
acceptez que malgré des des théories
complotistes elle soit il lui députée
conservatrice et membre de votre équipe
et vous ne donnez pas de renier ses
propos nous sommes dans une élection en
pleine d'une pandémie c'était une
mauvaise décision par le premier
ministre mais je suis ici comme un chef
avec un plan c'est la même chose avec
tous mes candidats et candidates un plan
pour notre avenir après des
manifestations au lard seulement c'était
inacceptable de bois ça avec le premier
ministre hongrois avoir un débat sur les
idées mais pour notre avenir vous ne
dénoncez pas un terminal de terminer sur
chérie gala vous ne dénoncez pas ses
propos on doit présenter un plan de
l'est canadien après la pandémie c'est
et
g2 attend pour tous les membres de notre
parti moi comme chef et tous nos
bénévoles d'avoir une approche positive
sur la canebière parlant garderie
le gouvernement de m dos a signé des
ententes avec sept provinces aux
territoires 30 milliards par réseau
universel de garderie le québec attend
un chèque de 6 milliards si vous êtes
élu premier ministre ce que vous
déchirez c'est tentant je vais
travailler avec le québec a su lagardère
et sur tulle et où les enjeux importants
pour le québec avec notre plan on va
aider tous les familles québécoises
immédiatement pendant cinq ou six ans
comme monsieur tout d'eau immédiatement
et on a un plan d'aidé les familles
pauvres les parts familles
les plus vulnérables avec une montant de
75 % de la culture de la garderie tout
en respectant à le système ici au québec
parce que ça fonctionne très bien et
pourquoi ça ne devrait pas qu'on
fonctionne et pour le reste du canada
selon le centre canadien pour les
politiques l'alternative d'un crédit
d'impôt ça arrive à la fin de l'année
les gens doivent débourser l'argent
toutes les semaines et là ce qui arrive
c'est que
ça donne l'illusion votre plan n'ont que
ça crée des places en garderie alors que
ça n'en crée pas que c'est ça l'urgence
actuellement de créer des places en
garderie en haut avec notre approche on
va avoir plus de place à travers le pays
mais les familles vont prendre les
décisions sur leur sort comme ce temps
sur la situation pour chaque famille et
on va aider tous les familles
immédiatement pas juste car en % dans
cinq ans et je vais collaborer avec 1er
mai nice le gru sur la garderie sur à
nos transferts en santé sans conditions
et surtout les enjeux importants pour
les québécois québécois c'est pourquoi
j'ai lancé notre plate forme est aussi
j'ai lancé mon contrat avec les
québécoises et les québécois sur mon
engagement ma vision pour un fédéralisme
de partenariat l'ancien gouverneur de la
banque du canada ses vignes pour les
estime que 300 mille femmes pourraient
se rendre sur le marché du travail s'il
avait accès
service de garde or pour plusieurs
encore une fois les crédits d'impôt ne
crée pas de places en garderie qu'est ce
que vous répondez à on va voir parce que
avec notre poche les familles vont avoir
plus de flexibilité
prowler circonstances et pour les heures
de travail tu es le travail les
décisions pour la famille et on doit
respecter les familles et donner l'aide
immédiatement petit clairement pour les
familles à faible revenu on va donner le
montant de 75 % et comme j'ai dit je
vais collaborer avec premier ministre le
groupe parce que j'ai beaucoup de
respect pour le système ici les
provinces demandent donc entre 60 et 1
28 milliard tout c'est tout de suite là
vous est-ce que vous donnez le 28 mai a
tout de suite tout de suite je vais
avoir une réunion avec tous les premiers
ministres dont mais la première 100
jours comme prime et ménez et j'ai déjà
dit que je vais augmenter les transferts
en santé par 6 % minimum par freiner
dans une façon un stable prévisible et
sans condition en plus je vais avoir des
investissements pour la santé mentale
des canadiens c'est le troisième palier
de notre plan pour le rétablissement du
canada c'est un enjeu important pour ma
femme me bacquet et moi la santé mentale
de nos jeunes et des investissements
pour les toxicomanes aussi parce que
après la pandémie on va avoir des défis
à travers le pays avec les féminicides
qu'ici au québec les toxicomanies à la
dépression dans nos jeunes et c'est
pourquoi c'est une priorité pour moi
comme preuve en est mais donc vous
prononcez toile sur le 28 milliards
parce que c'est ça que lily premier
ministre demande si on à voir une
croissance économique
6% est un minimum et je vais être l'art
comme une partenaire
mais c'est important aussi de respecter
les champs de compétences et j'ai dit ça
dans ma réunion avec premier ministre le
go sans condition un fédéralisme de
partenariat sur la situation dans le
csrd et les défis dans notre système de
santé on doit travailler ensemble on a
vu des étapes pendant la campagne par
monsieur to do compte que les autres
premiers ministres c'est le parrain du
fédéralisme de partenariat on doit
travailler ensemble sur le bien-être des
canadiens des québécois très bien les
juges les juges de la cour suprême
monsieur o toole est-ce qu'ils doivent
être bilingues et ils doivent parler
français et anglais comme par exemple
c'est le cas pour le vérificateur
général ou le commissaire à l'éthique
oui un engagement pour le français biel
a immédiatement ou une grange et agement
sérieux d'apprendre le français j'ai
appris mon français dans les forces
armées canadiennes une institution
fédérale c'est important
donc les compétences pour nos juges est
aussi un engagement et là on a vu ça
avec ma dame n'doye club et quelques
quelques autres juges et ça se met ça
serait mon approche c'est la même chose
avec madame simone j'ai beaucoup de
respect pour pour ces expériences est
important de voir un gouverneur général
autochtone mais un engagement sérieux de
respecter nos deux langues nationales
c'est pourquoi j'ai un contrat avec les
québécois et les québécoises je vais
protéger la langue la culture l'identité
québécoise comme un partenariat autour
pour madame simone vous avez vu ça fait
beaucoup réagir au canada dans les
communautés francophones limbes août à
l'eau du pays et tout plein de ça est-ce
que vous pensez que c'était une erreur
et on met encore en doute ses
compétences tout le monde sait que c'est
une femme remarquable
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour madame
scène et je sais que c'est possible de
d'améliorer votre français chaque jour
je travaille chaque jour sur mon
français c'est important pour moi et je
vais
à travailler avec madame st amand et
c'est très important de savoir des
dirigeants autochtones à cette heure-là
1 parce que la réconciliation est
important pour tous les canadiens et les
canadiennes
surtout le juste une petite précision je
pas sûr d'avoir bien compris votre
réponse sur le 28 milliards vous ne vous
engagez pas envoyer un chèque de 28
milliards aux provinces en santé sans
condition on a compris le 6 %
d'augmentation
saucier acquis mais pour monter le
transfert d'un coup vous dites je vais
négocier mais ça sera peut-être pas 28
milliards peut-être beaucoup moins haut
doit négocier comme les partenaires dans
notre pays mais les provinces meirieu un
approche
prévisible parce que après la pandémie
on doit améliorer notre système les ch
et celle des prêts à le système en
général les manifestations mais surtout
vous les avez vus vendredi entre autres
sa empêcher monsieur trudeau de de faire
son événement vous avez dénoncé ça
qu'est ce que vous dites à ces gens là
qui sont en colère et anne marie faisait
référence à sa ya dans votre partie des
gens aussi sain ce qu'ils soient
totalement en colère qui sont archi
compte la vaccination obligatoire qu'est
ce que vous dites à ces gens là pour
apaiser le débat on a une des marques le
cifor et on doit avoir des débats
respectueux pendant une quinzaines jeu
je ne parle tant pour l'ars allemands et
les actes a comme j'ai vu ici pourquoi
je vais dénoncer les manifestations
comme ça c'est totalement inacceptable
et c'est pourquoi j'ai une approche
positive et j'ai une attente pour tous
mes bénévoles d'avoir la même approche
après la pandémie on doit travailler
ensemble comme pays tous les partis tous
les niveaux de gouvernement sur les
défis devant nous si voyez les cas
d'hospitalisation
malheureusement puis incertaine
prévisions pas très drôle
malheureusement augmenté au pays est-ce
que vous excluez avis toujours de rendre
obligatoire la vaccination pour les
employés fédéraux comme j'ai dit jean
cau cage les vaccinations oui mais je
vais respecter les décisions des des
canadiens sur leur propre santé et comme
je dis endroit éduqué par forcer et j'ai
la même position que les syndicats et
les dirigeants dans le dans le les
fonctionnaires et monsieur trudeau a eu
d une proche de mélanger les gens sur un
sujet très important comme les vaccins
je suis fier de notre niveau de
vaccination parce que les canadiens à
travailler très fort contre la couvre 19
et on doit continuer d'avoir une
approche comme ça
monsieur o'toole je veux parler d'elle
médicale à mourir vous avez voté contre
le projet de loi qui voulait être
conforme à une décision de la cour
supérieure du québec et qui faisait
suite aussi un jugement de la cour
suprême pour voler médicale à mourir je
tourne autour de vous si l'ajout c'est
l'équivalent d'un régime étatique de
suicide alors si vous êtes élu est ce
que vous allez revenir en arrière est ce
que vous allez restreindre l'aide
médicale à mourir
non c'est un droit pour les canadiens
les canadiens j'ai des inquiétudes ainsi
que comme sur la santé mentale et les
plus variables j'ai travaillé comme une
bénévole comme un ancien combattant avec
les lives et terrain avec les blessures
mental et on doit avoir une approche à
sérieux sur la santé mentale mais l'aide
médicale à mourir est une doigts pour
les canadiens et on doit travailler avec
les groupes les les handicapés les
médecins de trouver un équilibre pour
les services avec l'assentiment des scpi
projet dans notre doux très récent la
dent que vous avez liriez en prenant le
pouvoir
comme les enchères
on va travailler avec les médecins parce
que comme j'ai dit c'est un droit
l'accès est un droit mais avec une
augmentation pour les canadiens avec les
conditions mentales on doit avoir une
approche
spécifique parce que c'est une décision
primordiale
une dernière question monsieur autour
pourquoi vous êtes prêts à payer 40 % du
coût de construction du fameux troisième
ligne hal entre grecs et lévis n'est pas
vous êtes question il n'ya pas d'étude
qui ont été présentées ce pas un projet
qui fait l'unanimité quand même au
québec pourquoi si vite dire oui on va
payer pour c'est un exemple de dunes
fédéralisme de partenariat les
municipalités sont en faveur
c'est une priorité pour le gouvernement
de monsieur legault et c'est important
pour les exportateurs pour les
entreprises pour les familles dans la
grande région de la capitale et je vais
être là comme un partenaire avec le même
monte à 2 le tramway une autre projet
pour le transport en commun et c'est
très important de respecter les
priorités sur les terrains pas à autoire
on a un approche avec ça avec monsieur
trudeau à toi c'est tous des ingérences
dans les champs de compétence et après
six ans les canadiens les québécois sont
tannés avec une approche aux trois situe
tout le temps et c'est pourquoi nous
sommes le seul parti là pour le
troisième lien c'est un priorité pour la
région et rental merci beaucoup de vous
être prêté à l'exercice vous aussi bonne
suite de campagne
merci beaucoup